good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday
day number two of toast friends and
family here nope toast friends and
family week
here at the morning toast i'm so excited
to be joined by what is turning out to
be a regular co-host for the morning
toast and i'm really thrilled about it
you're so
easy like this is just the best day i
feel like well first of all i love being
here you know that so
i'm having always available if you need
me
um but i feel like i'm always texting
you like
i've gotta be late you are and then you
show up right on time
i know i'm a panicker yeah but that's
what happens when you move out of the
city
uh huh and i couldn't get to my uber
today it was like a thing my hair's wet
whatever at least i have a botox this
time i'm good you look fabulous you have
botox you have a
wedding glow taylor's getting married in
like less than a month right yep less
than a month how do you feel about that
i feel good how do you feel i feel like
we didn't plan properly
i feel like like i am in panic mode
i feel like i bought a bunch of stuff at
home goods that i didn't need
i saw that but i actually liked those
pillows are you having like a moroccan
themed rehearsal dinner because that's
what
the vibe i got from all your pillows
yeah no it's a clambake
so yeah i those poofs didn't really
scream clambake
so we needed extra seating right and so
it's like 25 adults but like
a bunch of kids and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
forgot where the kids are gonna sit
so i was like you know poofs are great
if they like smear schmutz all over them
i'm gonna be fine with it and so
but so i'm like and it kind of pulls in
i don't know
honestly i don't know you know what now
that you said clambake i do
see the nautical aesthetic that those
pillows were serving this is why we're
friends
this is very friends so mazel tove i
honestly do not envy you
i had such a miserable time planning my
wedding they're the worst yeah yeah like
are you having fun or no cause
like some girls are like oh the best
time of my life
they're liars or delusional or heavily
medicated or we're just not like other
girls you know
i think we're honest i think we're
spazzes transparent
yes and i do think we're both a little
like type a
and like i was very easily triggered yes
well my first wedding planning i still
have ptsd from it oh my god i forgot
this is your second wedding and i kind
of am approaching this wedding like a
groom
like okay and i defer to tay for
everything so whenever she makes a
decision i'm like it's day's decision
like i'm actually i kind of like
like namaste put myself in this like
trance of just being like
zen and it's really fit like i get why
grooms don't freak out over weddings
is taylor donahue the bridezilla or are
you
she i'm not she if anyone's a bridezilla
it's her
she claudia i feel like if i asked her
that question she would give me a
different answer
because i love you i just don't really
believe you no we did a taste of taylor
together okay
so you can still listen to it and we
talked about the wedding and who's the
bridezill and who isn't and she kind of
copped to it
there was a moment where she was so her
friend is going to be the photographer
so
she was like she's like hooking us up
with prices and it's gonna be like super
easy we're playing for a travel yada
yada yada but tay was like
we need to build a structure for stacy
and i was like i don't know what that
means she's like
i'm like are you talking like la la
palooza
like when there's like scaffolding so
someone can climb up into a tower for an
angle
and she's like precisely and i'm what
you know what that's insane it's not
unheard of it is a little extreme but
like
i know you forget it but your instagram
is an important part of your business
and just like your life in general
and i know you don't treat it you know i
don't subscribe to that i know you don't
treat it as such because your instagram
looks like you put vaseline
on your camera lens but it is important
the photos are important and
actually i really respect taylor works
in videography
photography and production yeah so she
knows the importance of capturing the
moment
you my friend do not you'll capture the
moment like 45 minutes later no like
45 days later and be like best wedding
ever
truly well so yeah i mean i guess i
could see
taylor donahue kind of taking on that
role but yes
i would just love to be a fly on the
wall during your guys's weddings
conversations
i know i think it's gonna be i really
it's we're approaching it from like a
chill perspective
it's more of like a dinner party than a
wedding it's i mean 25 adults is like
not insane
so it's actually much more pleasurable
than last time
of course for sure for a million reasons
but no i know it can be a nightmare and
even still like
we're going over budget and it's just
like we're just like making snap
decisions i just like
now i'm at a place where like i'm doing
the thing that you do with the wedding
where it's like what budget and i'm like
i want a lighting designer to come in
and put chandeliers in the trees i heard
i saw your instagram story where you
were like
looking for a lighting designer in the
boston area
south philly and i was like this [ __ ]
is on crack
i'm i'm starting to lose it what the
[ __ ] is the lighting design
i'm also starving yeah yeah that's the
other thing i'm on this crazy diet where
all i eat is protein
i can't even have a vegetable that's not
a diet
i know it's starvation sentence it's
terrible
so but my literally my wedding jumpsuit
doesn't zip
well so this was my question because i
feel like the best part amongst
obviously all the things like marrying
the love of your life yes but a lesbian
wedding is like you can really get
creative
with like you could wear a white tuxedo
what is
taylor wearing what are you wearing so i
got a
jumpsuit off of asos love for 213
and love honestly it's chic as [ __ ] okay
and that is the so it's not available
anymore
spoiler alert um but it
it's like off the shoulder off the
shoulder
but it's got like a dramatic cover of my
arm because i'm insecure about my arms i
don't want to show my arm
so it covers the arms but it's still for
summer like everything else is open so
i'm not going to be sweating to death
summer wedding is tough i used to joke
that i wanted to have a winter
wonderland themed wedding outside in
december
i mean i kind of understand that no
amount of air conditioning was enough
for me no ever
and then it's like it's very simple it's
wide leg
and it has buckets which i love
i love a pocket and then like kind of
like a simple darted pleat which i'm not
sure what it really looks like yet
because it doesn't fit i'm really um
interested in the pockets i know dresses
with pockets are amazing but on your
wedding day what are you going to keep
in your pocket like lip gloss
oh some ciggies
i feel like i could see it i'm still
scared of my mom well she isn't everyone
i smoked once in front of her it was
when we were like we were in florida
on my birthday but right before i was
like literally going to serve my husband
with divorce papers oh so it was a dark
time for me and
it was dark and my friend was like oh we
couldn't find it because i thought
taylor was smoking a cigarette i was
like god
damn it no it's not my mom that's a
tough part of growing up like when your
like adult life starts to mesh with your
family life yes
and you're like starting to drink at
like family barbecues like you did in
college
yes and your parents are like who did i
raise yes
it's a tough part of growing up so but
my mom was like honey you're getting a
divorce
dude so but i i did quit smoking a while
ago
and how do you feel about miss it i miss
it i think it's chic and fab
were you one of those people who smoked
like in the morning uh
at times yes like in college i
definitely was
awakened what kind of cigarettes did you
smoke marble lights
interesting yeah sometimes capris when i
was in europe and felt fancy
you know what i find so interesting and
i feel like you'll actually relate to is
so many reality shows that i watch
every now and then you catch them
smoking cigarettes and luanne smoked
cigarettes and during dorinda smoked
cigarettes
um mj all the shots of sunset smoked
cigarettes
a lot of the real housewives of beverly
hills do lisa vanderpump when she got
like attacked in dubai
she went back to her hotel room with ken
and they were smoking cigarettes so many
of the vanderpump rules kids chris and
dodie okay is a
smoker and i just didn't know people
like smoked cigarettes anymore
i know it is i remember i was i forget
what was
when i was with a bunch of people and
they were talking about how like smoking
is so taboo and this was like
five or six years ago this is even
before juul existed
and i was like one of the only smokers
there at the time and i remember feeling
just like so insecure and like
you smell like that's the problem it's
like it's not just like you're
killing yourself which of course you are
it's terrible but like
it's offensive to those around you
secondhand smoke kills like
the teeth it's the worst i was listening
to heather mcdonald's podcast and she
did a really funny bit about how like
smoking is like chewy it's like old
school it is chewy but like
every kid in america has a vape so
that's gonna be the new
cigarette and here and riddle me this
okay
here's the thing with vaping is it's way
cleaner i you don't smell there's not
really a trace of it
however it that's what's bad about it
because then you can just do it wherever
like
imagine if i was in like i had to like i
remember one time i was smoking
in high school please no one tell my mom
about this episode
and sending it i had my friend hold
my cigarette so i could smoke it so i
wouldn't it wouldn't like be on my hands
because my mom was like such a tyrant
and i was so terrified of her
but like if i was in high school with
jewel are you [ __ ] jesus nuts
can i ask you a question yes when was
the first time you smoked a cigarette
like how did you get into the smoking
scene okay
so i was working at um a place in
hanging massachusetts called fire king
rest in peace
fire king is it a restaurant it was like
a bakery restaurant and i worked at the
bakery not to brag
and there was a hot boy that worked with
me that i had a crush on
because i did not yet know i was lesbian
and
um he smoked he invited me and my
friends up to a party and he was like
i'm gonna go inside of a cigarette i was
like
me too oh my god that's how it starts
that is exactly that is a cliche from a
movie how it starts yep and then i
remember i was
in appalachia building like roofs and
houses for
um like habitat for humanity exactly and
it was like all of us were away and i
remember
i'm gonna i'm gonna do it i'm gonna drop
it like it's hot kate bosworth was on it
with me
we talked about this last episode kpos
worth your because we would smoke
cigarettes together by the telephone the
like the um what's it called no the
telephone pole
no the cell phone the what's it called
phone what's this called
um and so then i was like oh this is
cool i'm doing it
yeah by the way this just goes to pool
by the way this just goes to prove the
theory like only cool people sponsor
us truly so truly but it was like on and
off throughout college then after and
then i just
i mean i just quit no when we met you
smoked cigarettes
did i yeah yeah i was like was i a heavy
smoker
like you were in a light one but i never
thought anything of it like i've
actually
never talked about this really really i
feel safe that my mom
is not going to watch this potentially
mom if you did i'm so sorry it's not
like the biggest secret i mean
you could have been doing crystal meth
like that's what i'm saying
right every time i do something bad i'm
like well i'm not doing crystal math
like that's my bar
for what's acceptable behavior you know
over the weekend i was with my parents
and we're talking about like tay and the
marriage and like kids in the future
and i was saying like i'm not caring but
i told them that tay and i had this
conversation where
taylor was like i'll carry yours you
carry mine and like we'll bond with each
other's
that's kind of like a nice idea and then
tay was like wait i don't want mine in
your body
that's so mean it's so accurate so fast
because she's like
was like a student athlete in college
like she's a drinker but she was like
she's square she's so funny i'm wild
was wild
so i just feel like i saw i told my
parents that and my mom was like had a
moment and she was like
i don't even like i want to know but
like i don't even want to know and i was
like you don't
you do and then my dad was like heroin
and i was like dad no
but see no unless you're not doing
heroin thank you
if you use that as like your bar
mentally like you will always be on the
right path like
sometimes i like act like i take really
shitty care of my body like i eat really
bad like i go to a lot of parties i
drink a lot
yep and then i wake up and i'm like you
know i should change my behavior and
then i'm like well i'm not doing crystal
meth
i could always be doing worse at your
birthday party
i became a tequila model oh 100 i was
telling
olivia's story and literally oh my god
i'm sorry i forgot
you were a repetitive rita
on my birthday like oh my god that's
actually one of my biggest pet peeves
without people
when people get drunk yeah and they get
[ __ ] up and they don't
stop repeating themselves and they're
telling you a story and they maybe like
lose their kind of thoughts so they
start
back at the beginning i was losing my
[ __ ] mind
i was just like girl does this story
ever and this is my party i've gotta go
mingle
okay tay was like trying to help me and
i was like i got it ted
you were a verbal terrorist like holding
people hostage
it was torture i totally forgot it's
funny now
i was hoping olivia was as [ __ ] up as
me
no she actually did mention it today the
next day
but you know we don't care we love you
oh my god
i'm literally crying i'm crying we have
a great show for you guys today taylor
is going to join me in discussing the
fast five stories and if you like what
you hear taylor is the host of the taste
of taylor
podcast which is available on all
platforms and she also hosts
a daily radio show just like this two
hours a day on patreon patreon.com
the taylor striker show remember when
you're screaming it drunk on your
friend's balcony oh i just thought we
would mention the last time taylor was
here
yes taylor and i were like let's go to
lunch after like who doesn't love a
lunch
ladies who lunch 12 o'clock we had lunch
we
stumbled out of the restaurant at about
four we wanted to go buy chanel bags
no you you wanted to get how dare you
dare you they were the one who brought
it up you [ __ ] [ __ ] i said
i would like chanel's around the corner
and then you were like let's get
best friend chanel bags i'm like that's
not a thing so then i realized i had
left my wallet at my friend jason
who lived uptown so i'm like all right
let's go run to jason's house grab my
wallet because i was there the last the
night before last year through a dinner
party for my high school friends that's
him love him
and i was like we'll get my wallet and
then we'll come back and of course we
ran to jason's he was like in the middle
of a meeting he has a really serious job
and he like he literally shoved us on
his balcony and like left alcohol
cakes like all this leftover food he had
from the dinner party we had the night
before
and we sat on his balcony for two hours
yep i got home at seven o'clock
same as i'm pulling up i realized i
completely forgot about theo
he hadn't been walked all day and i
walked into the house and i'm like i'm
forgetting something
what is it and i'm like oh my god theo
he was like literally waiting for me all
day i was so sad i was being such a bad
dog mom like being a delinquent
oh no i'm sorry yeah i have that
influence on people you do that without
me though i'm i'm not
we're both bad but should we go to lunch
today
i can't eat oh right i can't drink
and i have to work after and i don't
want to be a bad influence well i mean
then after the wedding we'll do it again
we'll do it again no that's
don't even i want to break my diet so
we're going to dive into the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
love island
now streaming after a year of being
cooped up at home it's time to let loose
take some risks and live it up no one
does that better than the singles on
love island now streaming on paramount
plus
watch as the islanders head to hawaii
pair up and try to not get eliminated
while facing the ultimate temptation
with the return of casa amor
and new challenges that will test their
relationships and friendships who's
being genuine and who's full of it
you decide what's going down and who
goes home with love and cash
plus don't miss love island exclusives
on paramount plus including live hits
behind the scenes footage and extra
episodes it's shaping up to be a summer
of romance passion and lots of drama
watch the claws come out and the tears
flow with the new season of love island
now streaming on paramount plus head to
paramount plus dot com slash
villa to try it for free we've been
recapping power uh
love island for the last couple weeks
it's my first season watching do you
watch
i watched two seasons ago like they
didn't do one during the pandemic right
uh i don't know because this is my first
season watching well we did one
like there was a guy named cashel on it
i think it was two seasons ago okay
and um we were addicted we have not yet
started it
we're just crazy but so good it's so
good you know one with paramount plus
it's so easy to watch i love the host
arielle i think she's awesome but she is
so much funnier on instagram like
that is such a sin that network tv does
where they don't let the host like live
she's gorgeous she's so funny um okay
there's a lot of news today the biggest
story of the day is prince harry's back
in the news he nabs a 20 million dollar
deal from penguin random house for a
memoir i'm here for it so he's getting
at least 20 million dollars
up front to public publish his memoirs
yes with the same
publisher that gave barack and michelle
obama a 65 million dollar book deal
as page six revealed harry has been
secretly writing a memoir for nearly a
year and he has sold it to penguin
random house
while the renegade royal said monday
he'll be donating all of the proceeds to
charity
it's yet to be made clear whether he
will keep the multi-million dollar
advance
whoa believed to be at least 20 million
according to publishing insights that's
the advance
yeah so basically how for those who
don't know how in advance works
is you get paid up front like what a
publisher thinks you're worth
and they're hoping you'll out earn that
so like let's say you get a
uh advance of five dollars you have to
then sell five dollars worth of books
before you can make any money so the
publisher has to sell 20 million dollars
worth of books
before harry gets any proceeds got it so
him saying that he's going to donate the
proceeds to charity
after is it if it's after that's like a
really kind of sneaky way of
vocalizing it because if you say that
i'm assuming you're donating your 20
million
advance that's a proceed no well yeah
it's an advantage here's the thing
truth i don't care either way like like
i'd like for him like because i feel
like
he needs to make money and like listen i
know it's like she's like like 20
million
actually yeah because he's a prince and
the whole security thing is a real thing
and he no longer has her through the
royal family yada yada yada yada
i am team harriet megan and here's why
because i am narcissistic and it reminds
me of me escaping from
very different it wasn't a royal family
but it was a wealthy prominent family
and so
when you're like [ __ ] your money [ __ ]
you i believe in me
i can do this on my own or at least some
version better of this it's actually a
really interesting perspective
i stand for it so that's why i'm super
duper team then i do want to say i do
think
now they are extremely financially set
with all of their netflix deals she has
a big disney plus deal
they started this company with oprah i
do think they currently after you know
leaving a year and a half ago i do
believe they have
generational wealth already acquired i
really do think how much do you think
they have like 100 she wrote a
children's book
i mean so netflix deal disney plus
voiceover
right 20 million dollars for a book
right she wrote a very popular new york
times best-selling children's book i
don't know how much money is in
children's books
um they started this mental health it's
like a um
virtual therapy type of company with
oprah right
um they're just they get paid like to
fart
i just love that they're like oh you're
going to try to control us with your
money
we're going to leave and we're going to
make so much more well let me ask you
your thoughts on this because you can
relate to a situation on a smaller scale
yes so it it's confusing i think for a
lot of people
who i feel like i want them to be
empowered like i want them to share
their story like things were so hard for
so long
and that's kind of one side of it
yes but then the other side of it is
like they're still very much
trying to emulate that they have a good
relationship with the queen
and they named the kid after the queen
yes and you know they go back to a lot
of different events
so it's like are you running away like i
just think there is some confusing
messaging yeah i do i
actually i really agree with that i
never even thought of it until you said
it there is
i mean i think that there's so much
smoke and mirrors and so much fake
like pretense [ __ ] in everyone who's
involved in that family
um it's just the way it works and it's
probably hard for harry to fully shake
it
yeah it's tough um but you know i mean
yeah that is where we differ because i
when i cut i ran
like i mean i mean i i
bounced everything behind well you
didn't have um
a kid which a kid always because the kid
is half royal
and you didn't leave with your husband
so it's harry's family you know so it's
that's
such a good point they're more tied to
them in a million different ways it was
easier for you to leave you're
totally right so she probably defers to
him so i think she's a truth teller or
at least
at least her truth teller and then i
think that he's probably like trying to
he's breaking away but also it's his
family it's hard to say to somebody just
completely abandon your family and you
know i mean it wouldn't be a good look
it's not natural
no so one other little piece of
information that i thought was worth
mentioning is that
harry's co-writer who's like an in
industry known as a power ghost writer
j r mo ranger is getting at least a
million dollars in the advance
damn yeah make that money honey yeah no
it's just like crazy how
and how interesting it is to watch them
what oh and they also have a huge
spotify deal
developing podcasts yeah so they're
completely fine yeah they're good
but they really are like so famous it's
so crazy this ghostwriter is a cutie
j.r moringer he can get it um so yeah i
don't know if he's going to be like
what what the the context of the book is
i have to imagine it'll be very similar
to the oprah internet i wouldn't say
more of the same but like
maybe there's got to be there's got to
be even more stories to tell right did
you read or like at all finding freedom
that like their approved biography by
those two
uh journalists i had started it it was
it was just like so boring no it was
like
so i don't like i don't know what the
right word is like
almost like propaganda like she stepped
it was like a hallmark movie
she stepped out of the limo he left the
palace
it was over like it was so like overly
romanticizing like what are you guys
trying to prove with this book like it
was just it was bizarre honestly
yeah i i'm i'm not going to read that
one
it's not for you but i actually do think
this will be super super interesting me
too
20 million man that's nuts also what do
you think about priyanka
shading them i [ __ ] loved it
okay i do have to say so the story is
basically all these celebrities are at
wimbledon kate middleton was there
obviously and then priyanka chopra was
there and didn't say hi to kate
middleton yes so the story was like
priyanka chopra didn't say hi to kate
middleton
and i actually think a more accurate
headline would have been future queen
doesn't say hi to random american
actress like i don't think the two of
them are friends yes they were both at
megan's wedding
i don't think it was like this
intentional snub by any means i
doubt kate knows who she is like for
real well when
the the story i read kate and prince
were whatever william yes
walked duke and duchess of cambridge
cambridge
walked in and everyone clapped okay
as is like protocol yeah and priyanka
did not
got it and like fixed her scarf instead
she probably probably did do that to
stand with her friend
i like that do i think william and kate
give a [ __ ] no no
no zero no but i actually i didn't read
that part i thought that they just like
didn't say hi
for sure she didn't like that's her
friend and she that's a loyal [ __ ] i
like yeah those are the people who
her friend who were who she believes
wronged her friend
right exactly i believe that for sure i
liked it and if that was me and like i
was friends with megan i would probably
do the same
right yeah you always want to surround
yourself with loyal people i would do
that for you you would do that for me oh
my god i would cut a [ __ ] who came for
you
same um this next story is actually
really crazy because even though i've
been really reluctant to talk about the
sex in the city revival and i think we
should talk about
why i feel that way yeah natasha is back
according to people magazine bridget
moynihan was spotted
on the set of new york of the sex and
the city revival in new york city
good bridget moynihan who played biggs
second wife natasha on saxon city
was spotted in new york city on monday
filming scenes for the new upcoming hbo
max sequel
and just like that photographers snapped
moynihan 50 on the streets of soho
wearing a blue short sleeve blouse
cream kneeling skirt and a tan gladiator
she was also carrying an oversized green
bag a fan named gregory litley spotted
moynihan 2 and shared footage of her
between takes on his instagram account
i don't know why that's a relevant piece
of information um but let's talk about
let's talk about a few things i think we
should start
kind of i don't think you and i have
ever really discussed i love you love
the idea of a revival
i am my name is taylor strecker and i'm
a sex and the singing addict okay i have
to say i'm a really big fan as well like
i watch both movies i've rewatched the
series it's it's a comfort show
so when i'm at home like i don't really
it's hard for me to sit down and watch
like a housewife because i'm like at
full attention
pausing rewinding taking notes like
literally i can watch sex in the city
and sopranos those are my two
over and over and over and over and over
again like and sexy is my favorite when
i'm like doing like stuff around the
house or like working and answering
emails i love it it's like a comfort to
me
so i have watched the series i swear to
god like 150 times
and what did you think about the movies
ass on ass on ask
what but i totally disagree i still
if it's on i'll be like cancel our plans
we have to watch this movie even though
you know
how you could say that abu dhabi is the
best
movie this is like you liking black
cherry white claw
okay i have to tell you something i've
let you guess like me enough okay
everyone likes black cherry white claw
the best it's a universal decision
you are a freak who likes natural lines
and you think that makes
you just like everyone else no you're
the freak okay
you are the freak i'm still my [ __ ] i
try my cherry
it's really good how dare you
how dare you continue to make fun of me
when you know that you like black cherry
too
you literally on your podcast like a
year ago made me so embarrassed
and i've never got so many dm's from
people being like i don't know what the
[ __ ] taylor's talking about
everyone likes black cherry best that's
like you
saying like i like grape tylenol
you know no one likes grapes exactly
my god [ __ ] wench so back to
me so now that we have the revival i'm
not sure how i feel like about an actual
revival
but i do know i'm not like dying for it
ever since kim cattrell
announced she wouldn't be back which
which begs it's a sin which begs the
question
first of all which character do you
think that you are i always thought i
was charlotte
wrongo i'm miranda cause she's a lesbian
well that's funny because i think i'm a
miranda too but i'm not a lesbian but i
just think like she's
i actually have this a whole chapter on
this in my book about how miranda has
been
so stigmatized by our generation as like
the worst one yes
justice for miranda when in reality yes
nobody's funnier
nobody's more relatable and at the end
of all the relationships in the show
yeah maybe equal with charlotte and
harry hers is so real and like a real
marriage she's a career woman
she's so successful she was the first
one to buy an apartment she had ralph
lauren paint in her home
yes she like she's just everything of
the sort and i think they did her dirty
with a lot of her hairstyles
and her outfits and people just kind of
labeled her as the weirdo
when if you actually watch the show with
some integrity yes you will realize like
she's the star she's hilarious we all
wanted to be the carrie
that was ass i know everybody wanted to
be the charlotte carrie's the worst
harry's the worst that's a part of
growing up realizing that homegirl is
the worst first of all back to natasha
had an affair with a married man yes
cheated on her fiance yes
took every single person in her life for
granted her friends were constantly
there for her
she was never giving enough attention to
their issues as she was they were giving
to her
never she was just like an animal and
like i'm sorry
liking kitten heels is not a personality
trait adulting
is knowing that carrie bradshaw is the
worst hundred percent and
i'm sure you can relate to this as
someone with financial freedom who
like works hard watching her
like that episode where she her her
condo's going
uh co-op her nathan break up for the
second time and he's going to sell that
apartment
and she doesn't have any money and she
needs like 30 grand she tries to get a
loan and the ladies like you don't even
have a job why would we give you a loan
she has like 900
in savings right and because she spent
it all on shoes shoes she has 40 000
worth of shoes and she literally gets
samantha offers the money
she says no miranda offers the money she
says no and charlotte doesn't offer the
money so she storms over to charlotte's
place and said why don't you offer me
the money and charlotte's like
because that's not a giant yeah and what
what it's my problem that you
don't have a financial literacy yes
and then she gives her her engagement
ring which we all know now through me
has no value whatsoever yes because if
that's why well i don't have my ring on
today because i'm writing the subway and
i get scared oh that's fair
right i know a lot of people who don't
wear the jewelry on the subway but uh
wusbin's ring
was i i mean the plan was to sell it and
get two new ones but
it's like worthless it's like it's like
a car it like you drive it off a lot and
it just like tanks in value
does it take in value like where was it
from a store
it was from quiet so does it take in
value
back at the store everywhere or just you
can just the diamond though no
um i'll say this oh [ __ ] it i'll tell
you how much it was you wanna know
yes it re he got it for around sixty
thousand
and i heard that i could get maybe
eleven thousand for it
you're kidding you're her so you're
better off insuring it and it's like
you're losing it and if you get robbed
or someone you know or you lose it like
that's
it actually holds more value in an
insurance form and that's not me
planning insurance fraud and that's not
you encouraging no audience to commit
insurance fraud which is a very serious
kitty i'm kidding
i'm kidding no but good to know but like
for real though can you imagine no
[Laughter]
um okay but so let's talk about natasha
because i'm not really sure
in what context she's going to be
brought back back
are together we have to assume now do
you want me to give you a spoiler do you
know
i read something no i don't want to hear
i heard big died but then i heard him on
set
so you sure you don't want to tell you
oh
no okay fine i mean listen if did you
hear that he died
no he well i heard he died but that was
before they were going to bring him back
yeah but now he's back so he's alive
samantha's toad's dead
hit by a boss yes exactly how would
samantha go out in like a really
fabulous way she'd like was that like
oh like remember that episode where um
that woman who looks like jennifer
coolidge but who's not jennifer coolidge
falls out of what falls out a window
yes yes that samantha will go out in a
fabulous similar type of way
yeah i'm so bored i could die i'm so
bored i could die and then she's gone
that's when the show was so epic like
the most random that's like darren
starr's thing like he thinks of the most
random
[ __ ] like plot lines and
fenner for foolish fight falls out a
window yep so good
so good okay so i know why natasha's
well
i have this i don't know but i could it
makes total sense why they brought her
back so you don't know this for sure
i read that where'd you read it page six
so it's definitely true everything on
page six is true everything except the
stuff about me don't read it can i just
tell you
i don't know yeah there was a script
okay
and if you don't want to get spoiled
press 30 seconds on the podcast app skip
ahead
carrie and big are in the middle of an
ugly divorce
good who the [ __ ] would want to be
married to her right
what a [ __ ] ungrateful wench so
they're getting a divorce and so natasha
must be coming back and i don't know
what capacity but like that carrie
probably reached out to her like
oh that's such a scary thing to do like
such a savior complex like yeah like oh
my god
remember ah when she like has big come
to ayden's country house
and like to talk about the girl he's
seeing
or when he calls after the affair and
she's like i'm sorry he's in my life
he's my friend what can i say it's like
you cheated
with him and it just is for aiden joe
curry anyway the life aiden ended up
having with that woman kathy who was
also a furniture designer and he had
three little kids yeah they were like
named
tater and tater tot yeah so happy for
him that's the life that he deserved
same but then he blew it by making out
with carrie and abu dhabi you know what
things happen in the middle east and
you know what i don't think it counts
back at home oh my god i don't think
they had to make such a big deal about
it it's not like they [ __ ] or like had
angels they just kiss
what would you rather them have sex or
have anal
anal anal doesn't count everybody knows
that
[Laughter]
yeah just ask all the girls who are
virgins down south right now
the girls just kidding guys that was the
thing knows when i want to
i'm a virgin uh no no you're not you're
getting married you're a virgin
are you excited to lose your virginity
on your wedding night
well i'm excited to still lose my butt
virginity are you nervous about yourself
you lose your virginity to taylor i'm so
scared all right maybe
um if you have any questions you can let
me know okay um
okay so thank you for spoiling that
you're welcome
and we're gonna keep going but today's
episode is also also brought to you by
jinx
theo's favorite sponsor my dog is a wolf
a hard-working man and comes from a long
line of show dogs
no i'm totally kidding modern dogs are
sleeping more lounging more and they're
not hunting and working as much as they
used to so to keep our pups happy and
healthy the most modern kibble falls
short on the nutrition
that dog needs like real quality
ingredients without the added
fillers dog parents you now can meet
jinx the internet's fastest growing
wellness brand
for your dog's new favorite kibble
treats and dental chews with
recipes proven to support digestion
immunity and heart health
designed by dog parents formulated by
pet nutritionists approved by
veterinarians and loved by dogs
jinx is all the love you have for your
dog packed into a tasty nutritious
kibble every recipe is crafted with real
protein superfood ingredients and a
patented probiotic packed together in a
complete
balanced kibble because dogs that eat
better live longer
jinx was designed with picky eaters in
mind so if your dog's
not obsessed with the food the jinx team
will make it right with their 100 money
back guarantee because they're so sure
that your dog will love it
try jinx and get 40 off your first
subscription order at thinkjinx.com
toast your dog deserves a cleaner kibble
designed for modern dog hood
that they actually want to eat and you
can feel good giving it to them
your dog will love it or your money back
so what are you waiting for 40
off at thinkjinx.com toast
t-h-i-n-k-j-i-n-x
dot com t-o-a-s-t i was just thinking
one more thing about the sex in the city
please reboot
i wonder if carrie's gonna get a nice
settlement and then she'll finally have
financial freedom
i actually would like that storyline i
would yeah because he's so
rich it's like i know he doesn't need
all that money
do they ever publish
because sex in the city is based off of
a series of books by candace bush now
who was the real john james preston in
new york's
like elite i have no idea please god
tell me it wasn't donald trump it could
have been though
no no right no i don't think so hold on
i'm going to google
real big well i know like they had
donald on like pretty early in the
seasons
ron galotti what's with him where's
ronnie
meet the man who inspired sex in the
city's mr big on bizarre magazine that
sounds legit is he hot
i'm about to tell you okay so
he's the former vogue in gq publisher
said to be the inspiration for
bradshaw's long-standing love interest
and eventual husband played on screen by
chris nothnoff
although no one knows for sure that
giladi is the man behind the character
consistent speculations
point to in that direction i don't have
a picture of him though i'm sorry i'm
i'm getting lost down this rabbit hole
yeah galati oh he's got a wife
oh miranda line oh my god here is a
picture
of mr big and ron galotti i think
oh ron galotti does not look like chris
noth no
kristina is much hotter yeah
yeah i love looking at pictures from
like when sex in the city
was on the air and they were all like so
so famous and like younger and they're
like
fabulous covers of magazines and like
paparazzi to different events it's like
such a fabulous like time capsule
i know it's like that's an error that
will never be again
no but it's so precious but you might be
saying that about this era in 20 years
i will be yeah everything just changes
okay
another story that's like fake news you
know it's like
all these headlines are like i'll just
read it to you okay i know what i'm
saying
haley baldwin shuts down pregnancy
rumors after husband calls
them mom and dad in an instagram photo
so basically
um they aren't expecting a baby despite
what fans on instagram
might think they went wild wondering
whether the parents they were parents to
be
after bieber posted a black and white
photo of him and haley and then
captioned it
mom and dad somebody i mean a million
people commented baby on the way what do
you mean mom and dad
and then hayley um wrote i think you
should maybe change this caption to dog
mom and dad before anyone gets it
twisted
so the whole outcome of this story is a
big nothing burger they're not pregnant
yeah how old are they they're young um
they're not like you know
inappropriately young
to have a child no he's 27 which
actually is like a nice
and haley bieber is
26 25
she was 24. oh she's young she's young
that's young to have a child but they
are
like super religious and traditional i
think in a lot of ways they're
successful like it's like they can
afford the [ __ ] out of a baby so
i mean i also just feel like as a model
haley's career has never been bigger and
i don't know if
she wants to like tame that i feel like
she's gonna be one of those girls that
just snaps
right back i know it actually makes me
upset it really makes me upset
um i mean i would be so here for them to
be parents i have hated justin bieber
for so long and
like the last two years i like adore him
why did you hate him because you had a
bad experience because i was serious and
it was really really bad oh i think you
told the story on the last time i did i
did
but like honestly now looking back that
was a that was my bad
yeah you know when you were telling me
the story you know my bad you know when
you're telling
like someone a story or you're hearing
something from someone and they're
talking about like you know a friend
that like
you know betrayed them and you're
listening to the story and you're like i
think you're the toxic one yep
i think i i did do remember feeling that
way when you're telling me the justin
bieber story like well you acted
inappropriately
i was out of control i was unhinged and
it was my bad i totally [ __ ] but he he
could have handled it a little bit
better given like i wasn't like being
mean to him i was joking with him
but ultimately like i should have
respected him more i think that he was
insecure because he was this kid trying
to be taken seriously as an adult
and i was an adult trying to like not
flirt with a child because that's
inappropriate and it just was like
an explosion especially such a good
looking child i know
so you're back on the biebs i'm back i'm
so deep and his music is so good
and i love the two of them together
she's a delight i think she makes them
better i'm just i stand them
she did wonders like for his image and
just for
i think him on like a personal level i
feel like you actually really did make
him a better person but also
publicly i feel like so many people like
stan them now when they used to think he
was like you know uh
a menace yes remember like when he got
like arrested for throwing eggs at his
neighbor's house that's suggesting that
i was like when i was on the air serious
that was like
where he was he was an [ __ ] yeah but
he was also like a child
exactly who grew up like with no
boundaries yeah so i feel like
you know what it's funny too i used to
be like so
anti like loving celebrities and stan
chip and all that stuff
and now i don't know i'm just like i'm
so happy with tay and i love her so much
and i feel like i'm like
i'm more open to like loving taylor
hurt people hurt people yeah and that
was you before you met tay i think it's
so true
and sometimes i just hate things because
it's funnier it's fine
yes yes like harry i got any content
like it's funnier
we have to eat some things of course
yeah and carry some people make it so
easy carrie brought y'all so easy thank
god what a gift
yeah i know and i actually feel like i
know people aren't their characters but
i think if there's any actress who's
most similar to the role that they play
even though i've never met sarah jessica
parker this is just a guesstimate
no it's her i actually will say i think
she's even worse
yeah than carrie yeah i think so too
more delusional
i still think she's fab and i'm still
obsessed but like i think she must be
the pitts magettes and i
and i've actually grown to love samantha
so much more obsessed
like sure what a great character what a
modern woman
owned her own pr company was so sexually
free
yes was so limitless in her judgments of
people like she's really
i'm telling you the show will suffer
immensely
immensely so i got to interview kim
that's serious and then like later that
day i went to
amaranth where we went with my mom and
my aunt and guess who was there
kim and they were like go say hannah's
like she's not gonna remember me and i
was on my way to the bathroom and i was
like
hi and she was like taylor like and that
is when you know someone is a celebrity
that's a real deal because
they can they're so allowed to forget
because they have so many
people exactly wow that's a great story
so she's actually
like even a good person you know i
really like the camera i recently
watched um
remember each hollywood stories yes they
were running some old ones on
e like on a saturday a couple months ago
and it was actually fabulous
and i was watching um the sex and the
city one where they did how everyone got
cast
what they did like a whole breakdown
what they were doing career-wise before
sex in the city how the show blew up
like really changed the
zeitgeist it was fascinating it was
outdated obviously because it hadn't
been updated in years but
it was really really interesting i want
to watch that and you know what i also
find really interesting i could talk
about sex in the city i could do a whole
podcast
like series about same i find really
interesting that as far as i know none
of the cast ever dated
which is uncommon for such a popular
show what do you mean oh
like big never dated charlotte in real
life got it i know
i don't think so either steve never
dated miranda you know well
well miranda loves me but you know what
i mean but no i will say though like
having worked with the younger cast
i feel like darren starr he's the head
of the ship and everything like
i think that his his shows and his cast
are amazing can we talk about the
younger finale
it already happened yes we can can we
i'm so confused because younger it did
air on paramount plus but like now it's
also airing
like no it aired it i watched it i
finished the finale everyone it's over
okay so if you didn't get okay great
it's over we can talk about it what the
[ __ ] i know
so it's not even let me tell you
something
it's not even about like did i want
charles for her verse did i want josh
but who did you want
honestly i thought liza was so goddamn
annoying i didn't give a [ __ ] who she
ended up with because whoever ended up
with her was going to be miserable and i
honestly felt bad for them
that's the truth so i didn't care i
wasn't obviously i
i leaned more towards charles obviously
i leaned more towards josh but only
because the show
literally was about charles eliza i
literally
forgot that he had dated she had dated
josh
he was so irrelevant so just to throw
him in in the last 20 seconds of the
show
there was no fluidity there was no
storyline that
is not a thing it was always there no
here's the thing
there's team josh and there's team
charles period end of story
and the team charles people i understand
why you would see that but as a team
joshua
i was watching the charles like when
it's going to end when's it going to end
how's it going not be team charles
because
ah again you're making it about yourself
of course
[Applause]
yes narcissism wearing it i mean i guess
that's
understandable for you but no normal
people
love charles i know i know i know he's
so hot
he is so hot did you see that there was
like a dumois blind that like this
really really famous tv couple
is going to be announcing a divorce soon
no and like
a lot of people were guessing because
they're both on tv that i was hitting
marishka but nothing ever happened
i don't remember hearing like a
follow-up that was like a month ago i
just and then i saw them at the nick
game and they were like very happily in
love so i just want to put it out there
like protect
them at all protect them in all costs
them and their family yeah no no i don't
think it's them me neither
like when the last time we were
recording the last couple times we
recorded he was in hawaii
like to get like on a family trip and he
seemed quite chipper oh and marishka was
there
yes oh my god i'm so jealous of that job
that you got with it it was so great
and it's over now right yeah do you keep
in touch you have any of their phone
numbers
you know what i always like respect it
because like when you work with like a
company like a viacom like there are so
so much chain of command and so the cast
is so [ __ ] cool and so
so nice to me and i of course want to
have them like on my podcast and stuff
yeah or like come over to my house
or like that too yeah and they've always
like
i think that now that the show's over
and like i'm not gonna step on pr's toes
i'm gonna start like reaching out to
them and having them come on
they're amazing niko's actually [ __ ]
great yeah miko now lives in jersey city
and so i think like the last time we
spoke nico was like let's get together
so i'm gonna
yes i'm going to continue relationships
with them that's a really hard part of
our job and i think it's one that
probably i could used the most help in
is like ben is amazing at networking so
good he can meet someone and will
literally be invited on a vacation with
them the next day like i know
i am so awkward same and it's such an
integral part of our job in terms of
like booking guests and just like
like knowing what's going on and i'm so
bad at it and it's something i'm like
consciously trying to work on but it
just feels so thirsty
like i just thought this yesterday
because i was thinking like i
had brian kelly mm-hmm finally auntie
taylor and i was like so not nervous to
ask but like
it just it was like it was something
that i had thought about and i was like
i don't want to bug you like you were
delighted
yeah so weird i don't know what the
issue is no it's it's something i deal
with too and it's like
indeed it honestly like if i was more if
i was more like ben
i would have my own daytime show like
ben is the
best [ __ ] networker of all time and
i'm so grateful for it
he's so great all right fourth story
kanye west is not gonna rap about
kim kardashian on his new album okay so
his new album is called donda
um it will likely be about a lot of
things uh sorry dondo will likely be
a lot of things to kanye west fans but a
diss album about kim kardashian is not
one of them
after a report claimed that kanye west
compares his marital home with ex-wife
kim kardashian to a prison on his new
record
rapping that he quote escaped from
calabasas page six can exclusively
reveal that that is not true oh
multiple sources confirmed to page six
that wes doesn't wrap anything negative
about his estranged wife on the new
album and certainly doesn't compare
himself to being a prisoner
or rap about her taking everything he
held a listening party in las vegas
sunday for some of his new songs
and an insider told page six kanye
actually played the song for him
personally before the listening party
it's emotional and personal not negative
at all
in fact west and kardashian are
co-parenting their four children
amicably
and even took a family trip to san
francisco over the weekend and the album
is named donda after his late mother who
died in 2007 from complications
following cosmetic surgery and she was
only 58.
so at this party which was fabulous um
they say
web personality justin laboy was there i
don't know who that is
but basketball star kevin durant it was
like a fabulous event
and honestly i wish that the media would
stop trying to come between like two
people co-parenting in a very happy way
i agree i think that um i in my opinion
i think that they got a divorce just
because
kind of what kim said when she was like
he deserves to be with somebody who can
follow him around
i'm not that person like you and they
were living separate lives exactly
i just think that yeah of course there's
like hurt there and they probably have
like rip-roaring fights but
ultimately i think we're in a really
good time now where
parents like yeah we get a divorce but
the goal is to co-parent these kids
properly so even if we have other
significant others i mean
divorce 10 15 20 years ago was always so
contentious atrocious
and now i feel like it's actually i'm
like proud of us
divorce people yes well you know what
also and everyone's situation is
different
but even if it was like a bad divorce i
don't think kanye would ever disrespect
him especially in a public way
because she's the mother of his children
and kanye is so that's exactly what i
was gonna say kanye is so fond of his
mother
he has donned a house which is like a
charity he the album is named after
donde she was such an influential part
of his life
i don't think you can be that type of
person who has so much respect for their
own mother
and then disrespect the mother of your
children even if you are going through
like
a not great situation so i don't think i
will believe and
until i hear a lyric that says [ __ ] kim
i will not believe that kanye has
anything bad to say about kim
because they have four kids and they're
both such family oriented people i mean
we know the kardashians are we know
kanye is well also the the kardashians
are a byproduct of a divorced family
like you know their mom
cheated on their father and look at how
they've all lived cohesively since i
mean and don't even start it on
caitlyn jenner i mean there's so many
thousands of lives of caitlyn jenner
oh my god so if you made a chart
yes of who people who caitlyn jenner was
married to and you started to connect
all the dots of other famous people in
hollywood who because you know
caitlyn was married to linda who's uh
bruce who's brody's brody's mom
linda yes linda thompson i think her
name is was married to
david foster david foster was married to
yolanda yolanda was married to muhammad
like you could connect how much all of
hollywood wings do they all have
the deeds kardashians and the fosters
are all very loosely related
and honestly who wouldn't want to be in
those families no i know like could god
i would literally be like the big fat
cousin like
oh no big fat claudia is coming gotta
restock the pantry
i i don't know i just feel like modern
family kind of was like a buzz term for
a while but like i think it's
being actualized now i think it's real i
don't think it's [ __ ]
me too except that like the fosters and
the hadids are no longer related because
david and yolanda
are divorced so do you think they were
like a blended family and like getting
along while they were married but then
it's like they're divorced i'm not
related to this person why do i need to
hang out with them yeah unless you're
super close
with somebody yeah which i don't think
that they were no um
all right fifth and final story is a
little space news because there's a lot
of rich people going to space and i
would love to hear your take on it
and the rich people going to space news
is brought to you by all
olive and june you guys know you cannot
possibly do your nails yourselves i have
tried it they always look
no turnt crusty as hell salon manicures
are also really expensive
and they always chip so it's like you're
left in this like shitty little place
and that's why that's where the olive
and june manicure system
comes in because now you know diy
manicures that look salon perfect and
last over seven days are possible
and everyone's gonna be asking what
salon you go to and then you're like nah
i did it for free at my house
so i have the olive and june manicure
system the best part okay the polishes
are everything they're organic
they're stunning colors but the mani
system comes with everything you need
for an at-home manicure so like cuticle
oil
a buffer a file like everything you
would like not even think of to get
and that really makes a difference in
how long the polish lasts on your
fingers and i use a cuticle oil like
every night before bed it's just like
a great thing because i have crusty
cuticles i need it um it's five steps
and it comes with poppy a patented brush
handle that makes it easy to paint with
both of your hands
it's also really affordable because six
polishes break down to two dollars a
manicure
and if you're used to spending around
thirty 30 for one gel manicure you'll
understand
how much of a deal this is the polish is
everything
it really does look like gel it does not
chip it lasted
longer than a week for me um and our
nails have never looked better it is a
secret behind salon perfect nails at
home all in one
no guessing no messy nails no salon
price tag and now you can get 20 off
your first manicure system with our code
toast
so your new nail life is here get 20 off
your first mani system when you use
promo code toast
at olivenjoon.com if you're done with
expensive bad manicures this is the new
the new us
i'm using it and i'm using your code oh
yeah by the way i actually have an extra
one here if you want it
it comes in also this great little pouch
i love pouches i was so embarrassed to
come here today like this oh my god what
are you gonna do on for your nails for
the wedding
i don't know just probably like light
pink light pink yeah all right
jeff bezos and his blue origin crew
complete a successful
space flight this was this morning he
wrote his own rocket amazon and blue
origin founder jeff bezos streaked into
space tuesday on a thrilling
10-minute up up-and-down flight a
high-tech joyride that sets the stage
for the start of commercial passenger
service
later this year competing head-to-head
with fellow billionaire richard branson
who flew into space aboard his virgin
galactic rocket plane
on july 11th bezos blasted off with his
brother mark and two history making
passengers
82 year old 82 year old aviation pioneer
wally funk
the oldest person to fly to space and
oliver damon an 18 year old dutch
student who is the youngest to ever fly
into space okay
and the oldest person wally funk was
barred from nasa initially because it
was an all-male astronaut corp in the
1960s
but jeff bezos finally gave her a chance
to prove the naysayers while he's a
woman
well yeah i was confused as well um and
she got to realize a lifelong dream so
they lifted off
from their west texas launch site at 9
12 a.m this morning
climbed straight up 110 000 pounds
of push the rocket rapidly accelerated
as it consumed its load of super cold
liquid oxygen
and hydrogen propellants pushing the
passengers back in the recliner seats
about three times the normal force of
gravity so it was successful
nobody you know nothing went wrong and
he made history with
two other people but he was the second
billionaire not the first
and if you're not first you're lost
exactly uh
he's just first loser wait a second yeah
are they still there
no it was 10 minutes but there was a
petition dumbest thing in the world
there was a petition on change.org that
165 000 people signed to make jeff bezos
stay in space
listen jeff
wait sorry to interrupt you which you've
been doing the whole time no don't they
say if a change.org position gets a
petition gets over a hundred thousand um
signatures the white house has to
respond
that's ridiculous i think that's like
the policies so imagine the white house
calls it they're gonna make
jeff you gotta stay in space everybody
hates you um so
how how much do we think that cost oh so
like millions and millions of dollars
but but jack jackie's a smart one here
so
don't ask me questions like because i
don't know the answer but i do believe
she said
i know when i do the news on my show
people ask questions i'm like you know
the rules like don't ask me questions
refer to the article
basically i think what jackie said was
like this is gearing up
so that like random rich people can pay
like 250 000
a seat yeah to go to space i believe
that's what
she had said so here's the thing so
let's say it cost 10 million let's just
say i think that's fair
i just feel like there's so many things
going on
in our world that that money could
better suit i said the same thing when
when we were talking about richard
branson
and i it's just like and these guys are
so insane like
is it besos who's on track to be a
trillionaire in like the next year
i think it's i think it was him see
that's just so much that's money you
can't even speak
just 50 lifetimes i just got out of a
pandemic like people are like
really in a bad spot like with taxpayers
like we're you know
we have to but like our taxes didn't go
up and
i listen i am not smart enough to have
this conversation i'm regurgitating
probably something my dad said
but it's like i hear that the rich
people like at that level they like
figure out a way to never pay taxes yeah
so it's like
at the very least take what you would
have been charged in taxes
give it to the government and let them
disburse it for important things yeah
like i think
he's such a selfish [ __ ] when you
compare like mackenzie bezos who's
also because she got half of his when
yeah when he was like
amen 36 billionaire i think she got or
no maybe she got 36 billion dollars yeah
she since then has given away over half
of her wealth because it's so much money
like what are you gonna do with that
much money so when you compare what his
ex-wife did versus what he's like doing
like taking joyrides into space
it's just like a little he sucks come on
jeffrey you can
do it pave the way put your back into it
come on now
have you ever seen i actually don't i
haven't even seen the bo burnham
i want to sing it with you know what i'm
talking about i don't okay so it's
actually all over tik tok and that's how
i know but you know
the beau burnham comedy special that's
going viral inside by bo burnham
i don't i tried to watch it when i was
in the hamptons with a bunch of people
and everyone was [ __ ] talking and it
was just like disrespecting the comedy
but it's like this musical he put
together during the pandemic in his
house where he's like singing funny
songs i guess i haven't seen it i don't
really know what it's about
but there's one about jeffrey bezos
that's gone completely viral on tick
tock
and it's so funny ceo entrepreneur
born in 1964 jeffrey
jeffrey behezos and it's literally been
stuck in my head all [ __ ] morning
um so sorry that's what i was saying
it's about just like jeffrey basil have
you seen it is it about him being yeah
the whole song is about jeffrey bates
yeah but there's other songs in this the
comedy special are about like other
things he just got nominated for an emmy
i think
is it about jeff bezos being the worst
yeah it's just like come on jeffrey you
can do it pave the way put your back
into it something like that
he could like turn around so many
generations in this country
snap of a finger with a press of a
button from his bank account you know
and it's just like okay you're gonna go
to space and try and like you know
make change up there like why don't you
just do it down here because he's ready
to bale ski
yeah i just like i'm going down with
earth i just want to say
i'm like so jealous of how much money
yes i mean
i uh but what a burden for real in a way
that's a burden i would welcome first
you know what [ __ ] what i just said
scratch that no i would do such good
things with
i pay off every student loan in the
country number one
because that is just ruining america yep
and then also like i do believe there
are a lot of really really good
organizations like giving money to
organizations is so great
yes but there's something more valuable
in just like knocking on people's doors
and paying their bills like you know
yes yes that's what i would do i just
like take my general debt
crippling the entire economy yes yes so
that's student loan debt is a great
place to start
yes and then i don't know work something
out with the colleges [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you universities [ __ ] you
colleges no i know you know did you
watch your college admissions scandal on
yes the dramatized thing yeah i thought
they actually did a really good job
because of course we know
from the college admissions scandal like
rich people cutting the line
but what i really took away is like kind
of how
corrupt corrupt the college system is
like especially like stanford
they literally it's a racketeering it's
the first time in american history where
a racketeering scandal has
benefited a billion dollar institution
they made seven hundred thousand dollars
that they claim to have given away
exactly it's i mean yes
screw the rich people who are paying
their kids way in but like what about
the
universities that got charged yeah we
knew that yes
it's so that was actually thought the
documentary was well done in that sense
because it gave you like a new
perspective like
all right we know like we hate
celebrities and rich people like that's
not a unique message for a documentary
but i actually thought that was a really
well done documentary what was it called
varsity blues or whatever yep
um well those were the fast five stories
and i definitely feel as though
they were well-rounded
i think so too yeah are you gonna go to
space no
i'm going to stay here if there was like
someone who was like i want to pay the
250 000
for you to go to space wait it's a 10
minute are we escaping earth because
it's
like it's just this is like a new thing
now it's going to become more popular
recreational space travel
girl i don't even have to go to tahiti
okay yeah or hawaii for that matter
i don't like to fly far so i certainly
don't need to it's only 11 minutes
though like the whole journey
it's stupid it's it's like the point
it's like going to the lean
tower of pisa it's it's a tourist
attraction yeah for sure
have you ever been to the leaning tower
no and i don't need to me neither i
heard it's falling
like why would i go see a broken
monument i'd rather go see something
like that's
all the monuments like the colosseum why
don't i want to see a smelly old half of
a building i'd rather go get drunk
with you at lunch no of course at a
restaurant that's fully built you know
exactly um so thank you so much for
being here you are a gem and a half if
you guys
want to hear more from taylor her
podcast taste of taylor is available
everywhere she actually just did a great
episode with tbg
and her daily radio show is patreon.com
the taylor striker show you go for two
hours every day right every day and it's
hysterical so if you're looking for some
more high-energy content from a
high-energy gal
maybe the only co-host i've ever had who
has more energy than me same
same energy check it out thank you for
being here i adore you
thank you guys for listening tomorrow
we've got another great co-host so don't
miss out and we'll see you then goodbye
you